so just because I was sick about having
an invitation to be able to ride with
it's like trying to try like write you
know sentences without like yeah person
like the letter e or things like that
it's just I had enough okay so or like
this this sentence no verb because
anyway so let's let's remember how do we
do differentiation right we said that
our differentiation was kind of an
operation you could do on a function
okay just like some across a 10 or a log
or something like that right so this is
our what we call the differential
operator okay when you see that in front
of something like say that means
differentiate F so we need some we need
some notation for a differentiation okay
so I'm still really getting it to the
full meaning of it but I just want a way
to write down well what's the reverse
process okay so here's the notation I'm
going to introduce right it is
effectively caught a squiggly thing if
you want to know what it is it's
actually the letter s stretched out okay
why is it the letter S I will explain
next to them but that's what it is
okay then then you sneak your function
in there now this is important right a
lot of friction we've been looking at
for instance this one right I think this
started with like the H or DT equals
something
okay and then you got an expression for
H okay so here I have
anti-differentiating
right but just like I can differentiate
with respect to X or with respect to T
or with respect to whatever variable I
like right I also need to be able to say
well okay what am i a to differentiate
with respect to so here I would have
done with respect to T that's my very
much there are my X is U so what makes
sense to have a DX right
so here if I have energy differentiating
with respect to X I'm gonna write the
dears yeah okay now any differentiation
differentiation there reverse
Precision's right so it's some senses
you ought to expect that he there's
division so he there's multiplication
okay yeah again if we're gonna get into
the intricacies of that later but at
least now you know how to write it okay
so I read this as anti differentiate F
with respect to X so this is what gives
me the primitive function okay okay all
right so now we could talk about it have
a look at the sheet that I've given you
where's my pile now I don't tend to
should do all of this today by any
stretch of the imagination but if you
are ever yesterday yesterday I
introduced primitive of of soil and
rational functions fractured lack of
faith and they end up as logs looks just
like a couple of very simple examples
sure that we could add to differentiate
n remember that what is the derivative
of what's the primitive of from 10 yeah
that's right
sorry minus plus C so this is the way
that I would write it down okay
I'm anti-differentiate an X with respect
to X I suppose I could do it any way I
like I could have had like you just
can't beat up with respect to theta cos
theta now I want to deal with these um
these rational functions did a bit more
detail because I didn't really address
the very careful yesterday so have a
look at the question the heading the
table where it says pretty all these
fractions
thank you see that desk assign another
video so don't look at the trig side if
you're looking if you're secretly
functors you're on the wrong side in the
other right so let's do this nice and
gently
okay so let's start off with number one
so how we're gonna write this
antiderivative the primitive write this
now I'm going to stick that DX over
there on the end because I've just got a
1 on the front it would have been the
same thing if I'd written it like this
DX okay because it's just a multiplier
okay it's just to be a lot of fun but
just to make it a little clearer I think
the one is more helpful right now these
rational functions right rational in
that it's a ratio it's a fraction that's
always be where we're sort of
anticipating that these are going to
lead to log functions okay so what I'm
looking for is something like this just
like just like this if I have the
integer it involves this kind of
fraction is special kind of function
okay so this is what we usually get out
of chain rule so if I had to
differentiate that I'm expecting this
log of whatever that is okay does that
make sense you see how if I have
different kid this this is where I'll
hit done okay
all right and have a look at this this
is pretty close but it's not quite f
dash on F is it what's the difference
yeah yeah I won a three up here now
Newberry is it easy to change
denominators not so much okay so what
I'm gonna do is if being that I want the
three on the top because that'll mean
it's in this format okay okay but since
I put one there I can't just as we seen
before
your multiplier numbers just because
convenient so at the same time I'm gonna
divide by three so there's no net change
here okay it's still the same thing it's
just like rationalize the denominator
you multiply by something you divide by
something no big deal
okay now this rational function is in
the form F dash so I can in two
different carry that one-third is not
being any different here so I just leave
it up front and then this is going to
turn into that's it okay now you can
kind of see if you once you get a bit
familiar with this right you'll look at
this right and you're ready done is it's
three times to spawn right it's not it's
it should be three times bigger right so
instead of writing this step you'll go
straight here after some practice
because you recognize that 3x plus two
is gonna stay in there but to make sure
that I differentiate them lay it back
here okay all right
okay okay
this time you told me what to do right
how am I gonna have to adjust in your
room I want to manage to up there right
because that's the derivative of the
denominator right so if I stick out
minus 2 up there how am I gonna have to
have a competent yeah Nick over 1/2 you
just watch out with your negatives
though it's easy to screw things up so I
need to differentiate with respect to X
and now it's in the right form f dash on
it so it's minus 1/2 at the foot tip
okay so in some senses this is just like
that it's just that you're gonna watch
out for they do I'm gonna skip a few I
don't want when you guys go back to this
exercise I want you to go back and do
the intermediate questions but let's
have a look at 9
now you can see it's more interesting
and it poses a different challenge
because it's not just off by a factor
it's not like I could multiply it by a
two or three or something like that and
it will turn into the for F - f okay
because if this is X plus three right if
that's how what f - it works with you
here what am I expecting just one right
and you can't just I can't as we've seen
before like with differentiation and
anti-differentiation you can't just
divide or multiply by X's because that
really screw stuff up badly multiplying
or dividing by numbers it's no big deal
okay X is you in trouble so how I fix
its up how do I get it into a form
that's gonna work for me now the answer
is well here I twist it and turn it into
something that worked by multiplication
or division
whichever now there's another operation
I can use you not multiplication
division something else that can help me
twist it into a more convenient form
right so instead of multiplication
division I can add or subtract that's
kind of haven't all that many options
apart with them right so what should I
add if I add three on the top okay now
why would I add three because I have a
thrill denominator right cuz this is
going to be convenient for me so if I
have an X plus 3 here like before I
can't just add 3 because I want to do
some kind of subtract it as well so this
is all still fine right these two it's
still equivalent okay now if I just
check some brackets around they just say
I could make it a little more obvious
right I can treat the numerator as two
separate fractions right so I can treat
this is X plus 3 or 2x plus 3 so that's
just what Rick and then I've got this
part left over which is minus 3 on X ok
and now this I could deal with yeah just
as I don't know sometimes you'll see in
textbooks or exams they'll write it like
this which is somewhat money because you
really ought to be you're ahead to
differentiate the whole
right so what does it turn into the one
year did you approach it and it becomes
X and this is well it's just three times
bigger than we'd expect it to be right
we simply turned into one on the front
so this is going to be minus 3 log X
plus 3 plus my constant okay